the Aston Martin db5 needs no
introduction it is arguably the dream
car of the 1960s and the most famous
bond mobile as fans will know the
legendary sports car came to
double-oh-seven s aid once again and his
latest on-screen adventure Skyfall
Aston Martin specialist beat rose has a
license to repair these cars his company
Rose engineering and Switzerland
services repairs and restores all of the
British car makers models
Aston Martin and bond go together like
vodka and martini roasts himself is now
a man with a very special mission to
restore the original db5 used in the
film Goldfinger talks like they do it's
the world's most famous car he says so
his team were surprised to be given the
honour of restoring this legend Jesus
become to feel outdoor he speculates
about the next James Bond saying I want
this car on behalf of a client Rose
acquired the car for around 2 million
euros and is completely rebuilding it
it's a tough assignment because this is
no ordinary db5
it's equipped with all of the gadgets q
invented for bond the radar device that
helps him track down the bad guys
machine guns fitted into the bumpers and
a smoke machine in the trunk that really
works but seem to think those explains
how the film crew burned a gas-soaked
rag or something like that in here then
they injected more oil and compressed
air and the mixture of the two created
the smoke what we now call foil smoke
you can still see traces of the carbon
deposits he doubts this would meet
modern co2 emission standards other
James Bond gadgets like the retractable
tire slashing were largely the result of
special-effects trickery decent pay in
the movie Q just screwed this part on
and presto it was finished old UNS that
declaw Tolosa type the db5 came out in
1963 and was produced until 1965 the DB
stands for David Brown Aston Martin's
longtime owner today a restored model
costs around three hundred thousand
euros with super spy equipment not
included
the four liters Street six-cylinder
engine generates 210 kilowatts of power
and propels the GT to a top speed of 240
kilometers an hour
M'Lynn base card sorry a Turing created
the db5 s iconic design the aluminum
body covers a very thin tube frame that
isn't terribly stable qs range of
weighty gadgets put additional strain on
the Goldfinger db5 in places the body
has weakened and cracked the seal Emoto
would give out in the film car was built
in record time in terms of weight things
were installed that weren't so great for
the chassis to make the vehicle safe and
roadworthy Rose says it needs to be
strengthened and modified to meet this
vehicle e OT secret height install
sympathy feet woes and his team still
have some work to do to get the
Goldfinger db5 ready for action again
until then its new owner can sit back
and enjoy a few martinis naturally
shaken not stirred